Brenda Johnson Gallagher 1997 ms school
of social work I thought when I came to
Columbia that I was going to have a
career in social work and I came to
school late in life got my degree in 30
years after my bachelor's degree I went
to Houston and was introduced to such a
world of not-for-profits in philanthropy
and with my degree it just opened doors
one thing that I loved doing was serving
on the Alumni trustee nominating
committee and that was a terrific honor
for me to serve on that committee
represent our school and there are so
many people at the school who shows such
a love of school we've started my count
to bergen county I and I love my group
last year we had 551 members just for
Bergen County and another hundred in
members in rockland county at McVicker
the downstairs where they had a
cafeteria and the mailboxes is very
small and cramped then our library was
in the CEPA building which is on
Amsterdam Avenue
to have the enhanced technology the
beautiful rooms everything in one
building is just tremendous it's just no
comparison it's magnificent here I
thought of all the things that I could
give towards that I would like to make a
difference that students could have an
opportunity to make friendships and to
have a place to meet and gather I feel
loved by my school there are so many
that i know and so many that i don't
know who have won this honor that now
it's a whole different feels like being
a part of a society or something the
Society of medal winners so it's a great
thing